the Joe Rogan experience part of the
reason I wanted to write this book is I
it's very much like you know another
thing I do is go around and talk about
science and religion and I'm an atheist
myself so I say that you know science
leads us to not believe in God and I
talk about this to very different
audiences churches and things like that
sometimes how's that go well it depends
very much on the age of the person in
the audience is the thing older people
like they mean up their minds they're
not they're not gonna change but young
people even a very very very religious
young people are fascinated by what I
have to say it's not that they changed
their mind right away but I've never
heard someone put it that way before
right and maybe they do change their
mind later maybe not but at least
they've heard a perspective that they
were not exposed to earlier I think the
same thing is true with quantum
mechanics like there's a buttload of
books about quantum mechanics on the
market there's no shortage of books
about quantum mechanics but they're
mostly with this spirit of isn't this
bizarres and this weird we'll never
understand it and I think that that many
many people who grew up to be physicists
this is what they're doing when they're
12 years old they're reading these books
right and so I wanted to write a book
which said like actually we could maybe
understand this if we just tried it's
not ineffably mysterious let's let's you
know be embarrassed that the field of
physics has not put its effort into it
and make an effort here and so maybe
that will so that's what my you know
most ambitious hope for a book like this
is that 20 years from now there'll be a
flood of young physicists who think this
is really interesting
yeah well the number what would you
estimate it would be currently like how
many people do you think yeah it's of
order a hundred that's it I think so
yeah like you know when we have
conferences it's often twelve people
there or 20 people holy [ __ ]
maybe there's more because I haven't met
them all but it always depends on how
you draw the boundaries also whereas
yeah there's thousands or tens of
thousands of people in most subfields of
physics so I mean why would you go into
the subfield where there's no money or
promotion chances it's yes but still
that's stunning when you hear that it's
somewhere around hundred I mean we have
here in California we have
sequin the California quantum
interpretation network which is a group
of us you know the people we know in
California who care about these issues
and meet to talk about them and it's
like 15 people Wow
and weekend it depends on where you draw
the boundaries and so forth when you
guys kicks the bucket I know that's how
we get to brink get new blood in there
yeah it's but like I said I do think
it's it's growing it's expanding and I'm
optimistic I tend to be optimistic you
know there is this yeah I alluded to it
before but let's emphasize it we turned
on the Large Hadron Collider in 2009 we
turned it on in 2008 and then it
exploded we fixed it and turn it on
again in 2009 and it found the Higgs
boson in 2012 and it didn't find
anything else and that's bad that's bad
for physics in a big way because it's
great that we had a theory that was the
king true with the Higgs boson but in
some sense we learned from the Large
Hadron Collider the smallest mount it
was possible for us to learn there's a
Higgs boson and that's it about quark
gluon plasma yeah that's great but we
knew it was there I mean well we'll
learn details about it but the
fundamental underlying laws that give
rise to that we've known since the 70s
hmm
so there's a million things we learned
about you know like for the
gravitational waves for measuring the
higgs boson we pin down numbers we
measure the Cosmic Microwave Background
the leftover radiation from the Big Bang
but you would like something more that
you could bring to people saying that
this is very very valuable and tangible
stuff well not just that I want to make
progress right so we had good reason to
think that there should be a bunch of
other particles that you discover at the
Large Hadron Collider and they weren't
there meanwhile we have very good reason
to think that 25% of the matter in the
universe is dark matter 25% of the
energy in the universe and we had very
good reason to hope that we could detect
it by now in an underground laboratory
and we haven't and it's there but it's
beyond our reach somehow so it's just so
hard to make progress under these
circumstances and meanwhile we have big
cool ideas like string theory that are
hard to connect
to the real world so this is the last
third of the book to me is you know
again like I have my favorite ideas but
there's a bigger picture about what
kinds of ideas we should pursue and how
we should pursue them so the last sort
of the book is maybe we need to
understand quantum mechanics to better
understand quantum gravity in the theory
of everything you know like what should
how should we expect to understand
quantum gravity if we don't understand
quantum mechanics come on
[Applause]